do you agree that we should give the
advice for a girl that wants to be
married would be to like sleep with as
little men as possible if you want to
get married to the highest value guy you
can I'm not saying like be a prude you
should want to marry a man that wants
you regardless you don't think your
choices have consequences and so you
don't think we should be honest to the
Next Generation saying hey these are the
consequences for those actions if you if
you get on the internet and you you post
your naked body like a guy that that's
worth it yeah
do the guys you want care is the
question there'll be some guys who don't
care but it's likely that those guys
that don't come not the guys you want